dr funiti mathur is a seasoned
researcher and an academician with over
17 years of experience in biotechnology
her research interests lie in peptide
synthesis analysis using hplc and nmr
solution confirmation and computer aided
drug designing
she is also associated with the
international center for genetic
engineering and biotechnology she is
responsible for equity accreditation and
ranking exercises as well as industry
academia partnerships at ahmet
university noida we are pleased to have
you with us ma'am over to you
thank you thank you very
much it's my pleasure to be here
at the symposium
should i share my screen now
yes ma'am you can
[Music]
yeah so is my screen visible
yes it is
uh
this is a
slideshow mode because i am not able to
see it in the slideshow and no man it's
not in the slide show mode
presentation
just a sec
[Music]
maybe you can click on the icon in the
stream right
yeah
down below extreme right below
uh
that was what i was
that's not looking like
yes
thank you okay thank you
thank you
okay so very good evening and i would
like to thank
the organizers for this
opportunity
so i was
asked to
talk about the bioinformatics
ecosystem at i'm at institute of
biotechnology
i'm at the university of the pradesh
campus
so uh
i would talk to you about
what are the various programs that we
have in bioinformatics here
i am currently heading the center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
at the amity institute of biotechnology
so uh here
the
uh the center for computational biology
and bioinformatics
is a part of
the amity institute of biotechnology
which
houses around
2500 students
across various disciplines in
biotechnology
and therefore we have five centers
in this institute
and i will be talking to you only about
one center which is computational
biology and bioinformatics
the other four centers relate to the
other aspects of biotechnology namely
molecular biology or medical
biotechnology or biochemical engineering
and plant biotech
so here we have a very nice amalgamation
of various disciplines in biotechnology
which promotes interdisciplinary
research
so i take pride in
introducing you to the center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
so the center in this institute contains
14 faculty members
and we are
covering almost the whole expanse of
bioinformatics as well as our research
interests are concerned
so right from molecular modeling to drug
design
systems biology systems medicine
ai
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
clinical research so these are the
various areas in which we are faculty
members who who
do their research
now
before i go further i thought i would
just introduce a slide on
the emphasis of the government of india
on
biotechnology
in the next few years
and i wanted to show you this graph
which says that
the
which shows you the growth of the buyer
economy that means i'm of course talking
about the indian buy economy here
so the way it has
improved the last four five years the
way it has progressed you're going to
see
that we are in towards a 150 million us
dollars by 2025.
and therefore if you consider all the
verticals of biotechnology that means
the agriculture the bio-industrial the
bio farmer
and also the bio i.t
where we specialize so you can see that
in the last five years
the economy has
grown
almost it has doubled over the last five
years
and we are going to go even faster in
the next five years and so
i think
this slide itself shows you the kind of
opportunities
that biotechnology has to offer in
general
and in particular bioinformatics
i think this pandemic has given a boost
to bioinformatics
the
i think every
common man today
knows
uh
what is a virus and in fact ngs the what
are the ngs how are we able to
get the
drugs for
overnight
pandemic and why is sequencing important
what are various trains so these are
uh you know this is a language that has
become a common man's language today
and therefore
when it comes to you know identifying
various strains of the virus
it is a sequencer which becomes very
important and the moment we talk about
sequencing next generation sequencing
bioinformatics itself plays a very very
important role
so
you can all understand the way
bioinformatics is going to progress in
the next five years it's going to be
phenomenal
and therefore
we need manpower we need
students of today who
understand
the various aspects of bioinformatics
were able to contribute to the growth of
bioinformatics in the coming years
and to facilitate that
at aib noida we have various programs in
bioinformatics at various levels
starting from bachelor level to masters
to doctoral level
and also some certificate courses
so at the bachelor level we have big
tech bioinformatics which is a four year
undergraduate course
and we have approximately 100 students
in the bioinformatics program
which which amounts to approximately
20 or 25 students per batch
we also repeated bioinformatics
international i'll be talking to you in
detail about these programs in the next
slide
we also have we take biotechnology with
a specialization in bioinformatics
at the masters level we have two
programs and tech bioinformatics and msc
bioinformatics
both of them are
two-year programs
at the doctoral level we have a phd in
bioinformatics
and along with all this we also
are running a certificate course and the
certificate course is artificial
intelligence in healthcare and
biotechnology we have very recently
launched this course
and it has been launched with the idea
of the demand of industry
in ai and
machine learning in the area of
healthcare and biotechnology because
there is huge industrial demand for
these kind of trained professionals we
launched this course
and uh but this is uh
availability of the post graduation
so uh
and all these programs that we have
developed here
i must mention that
the bt bioinformatics is our flagship
program which started way back in 2004
so our first batch of bioinformatics
students passed out in 2008.
so we are well established into this
education in bioinformatics
and over the years we have learned and
we are continuously improving our
programs
we have designed these programs keeping
in view
the uh
the international society for
computational biology the competencies
that have been
uh you know elucidated by iscb the
international society for computational
biology so keeping those competencies in
mind
and the
level of each competency at
different programs we have decided we
have chopped out the
objectives and the learning outcomes of
fda program
so uh bachelor level programs the beta
bioinformatics program is a 187 credit
unit program
where we teach
various
different aspects we start with
a biotechnology or base
so in the first year we teach various
science subjects
and then we start teaching basic
biotechnology subjects
and from thoughts and restaurants that
is when we are in second year when we
start introducing various programming
languages the logics of programming
then we
are in bioconductor python
and then we're going to genomics
proteomics so so that's how we have
evolved our program so the basic
knowledge of biotechnology is absolutely
essential for any person who is studying
bioinformatics
we have another program which is a
slight twist
it is beaten by informatics for an
honors degree
whenever we say it is an honors degree
that means the student has to own 22
extra credits
so i would other than 187 credit units
the student needs to earn 22 extra
credits to all the women's degree and
that honest degree is available in data
science and analytics cloud computing ai
and ml so these are the
online degrees that we offer
so
in the beta bioinformatics international
program
it is again
one of its kind program where we are
into
an agreement with indiana university in
the us
so the students would spend two years at
amityvida at with us
and the next two years they would
be at indiana university us and they
would finally graduate with a degree in
biomedical informatics from indiana
university
uh we also have beaten biotechnology
with specialization in bioinformatics
again the student has to own 22 extra
credits but you will do a bt
biotechnology and you can study
five or six more subjects in
bioinformatics so you get a
specialization so that is how what i'm
trying to tell you is we have programs
which are exclusively in bioinformatics
plus we also support other programs with
bioinformatics subjects
i
i don't know if you're aware but most of
my indian friends would be aware that we
have a national new education policy
that has come up in 2020
and uh
in that we have we are not going to have
all four years of undergraduate programs
bsc programs so in there also we are a
support uh
center for
for bsc biotechnology so that means that
we offer bioinformatics courses and the
estimate technology also
the master's very programs
again nsc and mtech
what is the difference between the two
programs as you can see it is there a
difference in credit units
and also the eligibility because in nfc
bioinformatics the eligibility is a
three-year bsc biotechnology or a life
sciences whereas for empty
bioinformatics if you need an admission
there then the eligibility
four-year date of biotech or
bioinformatics program
the certified course that i was talking
to you about there is a six-month
certificate in ai in healthcare and
biotechnology
we have actually developed this course
very rigorously very extensively to the
life sciences sector skill development
council this is a government of india
enterprise
and they are focused on developing
skills
with higher educational institution so
we have collaborated with them
and it is certified this particular
certificate course has been certified by
a triple s dc
government of india
so uh even those we actually came across
a lot of people a lot of doctors also
who which wish to do anyway course so
keeping that in mind we have launched
this kind of a certificate course and
i'm sure a lot of students
we are already getting a lot of course
regarding this course and i
i hope it's going to really serve the
purpose it has been designed for
a very attractive option that anthony
university offers is a study abroad
program
so study abroad option is available for
all programs
whether it is a bachelor program or a
master's program and we study abroad
programs
are open to our students at various
campuses of amity at london new york
singapore and dubai
because amity has campuses in all these
places so students from any program if
they wish they can choose to study
abroad for a few months
now coming to work
other than teaching
how else are students involved
we actually place a lot of emphasis in
on learning by doing
so other than the theoretical knowledge
that we give in our classes we want
students to be hands-on
and therefore we have various
non-teaching credit courses
that we call during our programs so when
the students join in after the first
year we do we do a term paper
which is a literature search basically
so we teach we you know the student gets
to learn how to you know say read
a plethora of
papers research papers on a particular
topic and then synthesize it into
a
report
right on this to
on the students uh end and we have a
strong plagiarism check for it so the
students cannot cut copy paste anything
so this is this helps the students in
reading and understanding comprehending
analyzing right synthesizing
then we have a summer internship so we
have students who are allotted topics
by their faculty members
students also do it
at industries and academic institutions
or
research institutions in india and
abroad
uh summer internship
usually lasts for two months
major project is a
is actually um high credit
non-teaching credit course where the
students have to complete a project
and this is largely of this is a very
large duration it varies from three to
six months students will be
required to do a major project and these
are all credit courses so the credits
are counted towards the final
grade point average
visitation happens for master students
so what you see on the screen are just
screenshots
of
what the uh students do so you see that
there are publications in various
journals and
i do not know if you are able to see but
if you are able to see names here these
are our bachelor's and master's students
who are publishing in various
journals so they're publishing in
scientific reports computers in biology
medicine
in general biomolecular structure
dynamics
and you must fill the nature general
journals so many journals so we
using these kind of trainings that we
provide to students we encourage them to
publish and that is why our students
when they apply for their post
graduation or they won't apply for jobs
i think we prepare them well for this
through this initiative of ours
so uh continuing student progression how
we handle this is when the students
join us we ask them to fill a student
aspirational survey and that is what
this sas stands for student aspiration
survey so the student is asked what what
does the student want to do
he or she wants to go into a higher
education
or the student wants to
stop have a startup after completing
their graduation or they want to opt for
a placement
so we offer on-campus placement students
or they want to appear in competitive
exams and they want to
go and change their line
so once we have this kind of a
idea of what the student wants to do we
accordingly groove students so we have
uh you know centers for all these things
and the students are grieved accordingly
depending upon what their aspirations
are
and in that uh this is an example we
have had a workshop on the beta and ai
in biotech and healthcare in 2019 and
this was in collaboration with the
umbrella
uk and it was sponsored by the
department of science and technology the
department of biotechnology which are
the uh
which which are a part of the ministry
of science and technology government of
india so this was a very successful
workshop that we had and we had a lot of
participants
and after this even last year we had a
virtual symposium which was attended by
a number of
uh participants and we had around 800
participants all over the world for this
workshop so this
actually gives a very very good uh
you know
experience to our students to see what
is happening across the world when
people from different parts of the world
come and talk about various aspects of
bioinformatics students get a totally
different perspective
these are an example of the various
places where students do their
internships their major project so these
are leading academic and research
organizations in india along with the
industries like bayercon nova zines
premars syrian institute of india so
these are the various industries that
our students do their research with and
since we are also had an mla with prime
biotech i understand we have around 30
students who are having their
internships with prime biotech this time
so we are looking forward to those
students and the kind of work they do
and i'm sure the fine biotech and
amateur university together we are going
to
produce some very good internships
so i also thought let me give you a
quick insight into the faculty that are
now present here as i told you we have a
total of 14 faculty members here
so we're working in different areas of
uh continuing drug design network
biology that is myself dr abhishek
working in systems of biology data
analytics
immune informatics to priyanka narayan
working in machine learning applications
in healthcare dr hina bansal
working in network pharmacology
working on molecular dynamics
simulations docking studies
dr majesa
again working in quantum mechanics
molecular mechanics
dr jiren is a
statistician and has immense uh
experience in statistics so he's an
asset when it comes to statistical
analysis dr kamel robel is doing very
good work in ai and ml
and
clinical research so
now the faculty members that you see on
your screen now these are computer
science faculty so we have a very good
interesting mix of
faculty members with the biotechnology
background with the bioinformatics
program and the computer science
background so that gives us a
very good place to be in
so that is why the quality of work that
students do
is really good it is quality so we can
really publish the work that we do
because of the input of so many
different faculty members with different
backgrounds
uh
this is to give you an idea that this
the research projects that go on at amit
institute of biotechnology we currently
uh
we have had about 113 funded research
projects from various government
fundamentals in india and abroad
and uh
the combined grand theft auto receivers
of the order of around 44 crores
and
i think mostly more than 80 percent of
the projects that have been granted
they
have some input of bioinformatics there
so uh i'm not saying that these
projects are all bioinformatics no no
they are all biotech projects but we
have problems which we can solve using
bioinformatics also so bioinformatics
comes as a very good
support to
the biotech problems
that come up
and uh there are we have
right now the bioinformatics center
itself has around five projects which
are running uh exclusively in
bioinformatics
so uh i was also asked to give you a
little understanding of the kind of
research that goes on at a center here
and uh this is to
show you some research that we have
published that we've been doing so it
says in my um
laboratory right now we are working we
published this paper uh very recently
and this is on government and
therapeutic so we choose chose the
protein facing kindness too
and uh uh we already know that ceramic
asserted is a compound that is supposed
that binds to casing is true
and this is
we try to modify to
to generate a compound which
has a superior performance emit asserted
because it has somewhat assertive has
problems of toxicity and side effects so
we use device biologist replacement
techniques and design phonographers
combining them
and
using modern dynamics to come up with
promising leads
so this was one of our work that we have
recently published another work that we
did was we designed a database called as
potential which we also published
earlier this year
so potential is actually a manually
curated compendium of peptides which
contain unnatural amino acids
so uh a lot of work we realize a lot of
work has been done in peptides which
contain unnatural amino acids and these
peptides
uh have a lot of
functions also
so uh
people have been doing a lot of protein
engineering so these unnatural amino
acids basically are integrated into
natural peptide sequencing sequences to
give them a particular secondary
structure so protein engineering
in that particular field i think this
potential can be a really good resource
because this is a repository of various
secondary structures
that have been made in by incorporation
of natural amino acids so when a person
is doing a protein
problem protein design problem and he or
she wants to
you know insert a particular secondary
structure at a particular region of the
protein
there
if we use
this particular
database they can get different
structures like alpha helix
fl construction or three pin helices or
beta sheets or turns
so this is something that we could put
together and we could publish in the
international journal of type research
and therapeutics and this could also be
sort of uh
help us in a future
you know endeavors of
developing some
machine learning
models
now this particular peptide-based
laboratory is activated so this is a
project that was funded by the
department of biotechnology in my lab
and here we have we have actually uh
done some good work here where we could
do some in silicon work so
is much is a protein which is implicated
in diabetes so we
can we design look around as activators
which bring to the electric side of this
protein
and these these activators have shown
to be really important in managing type
2 diabetes so we again used a
pharmacophores and we have used
from the mean gtas
and we have used talking studies and
dynamic studies to
arrive at a few peptide sequences that
could be happen that could act as
potentials
and then we
going to step ahead and with my
collaborators in this institute
we actually synthesize these peptides
purified then
and they did some biological activity
tests so this was a quite a complete
study that you could do and this process
this is in the process of publication
right now
so uh these are other faculty members
so they are doing a lot of work on
metabolic model reconstruction
they are doing
uh clinical data analytics and
associations
so
that's how you see that we are looking
at different areas of bioinformatics and
we complement each other
um
dr kamel gravel as i told you initially
he is leading a group on
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and he has developed
various pipelines from this group and he
is also heavily funded by the government
of india
the department of biotechnology
department of science and technology the
icmr
have all funded his uh projects and he
is into immunology and vaccinology
so
you saw a lot of work on informatics
vaccine uh candidate development so
these are the rarest pipelines so if you
get a chance you must try and look at
these pipelines which are uh
in
which which are actually an asset when
it comes to vaccine discovery and it's
done a lot of work
so during
so this was just to give you and
[Music]
you know a deep
peek into what the
[Music]
uh
our center the center for computational
biology bioinformatics at american
university pradesh noida campus system
so uh
i think i would stop here because my
rest of the side was just about amateur
university so i think i have just
i think i just crossed my time so i
should stop here
so thanks a lot for attention